there's a sample at the Museum that most
people don't get to see which is the
archive and this is one of the archives
which has some of the machines out that
are on display for those people that are
that are interested and you're lucky
enough to see it in the museum there's
over a thousand different systems
different machines in the collection
that's not multiples with the same lots
of BBC micros and things it's actually
independent different systems could be
different models but over a thousand
machines there's quite a lot of it is in
their original boxes and there's
somewhere else so any machines that we
have that are in their original
packaging are stored in the other
building but over here we have some of
the machines that are a bit too big to
go in boxes and actually are kind of
interesting so we want to put them out
on shelves so a storage bits storage
that you can have a bit of a nose around
so this is kind of like the special
stuff yeah this is for the connoisseur
and if you ask nicely sometimes we can
we can bring people over and show them
we number every shelf and when you go on
our website so if you want to see any of
these machines they're all on our
website somewhere and we can look at the
backing of the system to say right that
machine is on a shelf one one six in the
the the store that we're in now so we
can find this stuff pretty quickly at
least that's the idea but it is random
so there's there's no correlation
between that machine there and that one
it's you know these things are just on
shelves so we can find them but there is
a lot of interesting stuff here some
very rare stuff some common garden stuff
as well but but yeah just to go through
a little bit of it I don't even know
where you start with this but we have
some machines up here acorn fans might
recognize systems like this and
specifically these ones so we've got a
consistent 3a system five but this is
Steve Ferber's prototype it's kind of
the prototype of the prototype really
there was machine called the proton
which would later become the BBC micro
well this is the kind of the prototype
that promote the proton was based on
this machine and there was a very first
machine that he made at the top there
it's entirely home designed including
anodizing the aluminium in the kitchen
sink in things like
so bill they corn stuff going on over
here we have some nice Apple IMAX we've
got all the different colors and some
Apple twos as well there's also some
clone machines so that's a clone of the
Apple 2 back when it was possible to do
such a thing
yeah I mean this was a licensed cloak so
Apple did allow certain manufacturers to
make their own versions of the machines
that is also a clone of an Apple 2 with
this drives built-in I'm not sure how
legit that one was the Euro plus the
Apple 2e things like that but then
there's other machines as well that are
somewhat less common we have the ICL
systems up their interest and effect but
if you can see that this machine is not
on but you can still see what it was
doing something called scream bone so if
a machine was left on with the same
display on the screen all the time it
would actually burn that into the
phosphor bit of a shame it's kind of an
interesting thing so you can see the
software that were using probably a word
processor or something other early
that's a compact disk recorder a little
bit bigger and there's a CD radio as
well so yeah some really only stuff
that's kind of quite a bit of a joke
really to see something like that on a
shelf where is it's now just literally a
an internal CD roll in most machines
Atari ST a there that's a prototype of
the Acorn business machine so we have
some really early interesting stuff hey
that's pretty much unique that's a later
torch UNIX based machine torch started
off by making business computers but
based on BBC micros so have a BBC micro
with a user a tico processor and sell it
as a CPM machine that is kind of
effectively the prototype of this
machine here acorn business computer
again you know they're not necessarily
sat next to each other maybe we will at
some point but in the minutes really
know about what stuff is here rather
than precisely where it is it's quite
nice in that respect because you kind of
happen upon things you an expense is
true yeah yeah you might find things you
weren't looking for this was very
uncommon
that's the Olympia people CPM base
machine CPM is a language so CPM was out
there kind of early dose system so dust
was so basically effectively I got to
choose my words carefully here das was
kind of a ripoff of CPM
so there was a language called kudos
quick and dirty operated system which
was kind of a bit of a copy of
CPM and CPM was a language used by lots
of machines said a tea based machines
and and very much more business oriented
so you had lots of spreadsheets and
where processes would run on cp/m
operating systems we've got very early
pet down there with a chiclet keyboard
the first incarnations had the cassette
deck built-in so it had this very small
little keyboard obviously you couldn't
have a full-size keyboard because of the
cassette deck but that made it a little
bit tricky disciple so the original pet
2001 series with those keyboards are
fairly uncommon now most of them were
replaced or people aren't ready to the
full-size keyboards which are over there
somewhere I quite like certain graphics
they just look lovely the way they look
that machines you need to own very
powerful machines incredibly expensive
at the time most of these kind of things
all the silica stuff then silicon
graphic stuff we get it's usually from
universities or you know I say high in
broadcast systems and and render films
and stuff like that research machines
produce computers for use in education
if you're in the UK anyway a lot of
people remember those from school if
you're 40-something like me and the far
as he said was kind of a networked
machine that a lot of people had in
schools and remember from school they do
there's any beta system this thing's a
beast computer they're from Zenith with
a hard drive or Winchester as they
called it built in with its monitor
there on top is an HP 85 unit Picard's
machines very very popular use machine
therefore a lot of scientific and very
solid work of that nature
NeXT's lab so this is Steve Jobs's
company next after he was ousted from
Apple produce this beautiful machine
this is the slab normally sits down this
way and then you also produce the cube
which we have out and display very
powerful machines but in true Steve Jobs
style very expensive the next step up
rating system would like to become the
Mac OS system it was based on the same
sort of UNIX based system that the next
system used what else I have no idea
what that is it's probably a Power Tran
system I have to look that one up so
lots of single board computers back in
the early 80s UK 101 NASSCOM and I think
it was ETA I produce and
instructions you could buy their
magazine and build your own computer and
power Tran was the the name of that
system there so I think that's what
everybody is very big huggable Toshiba
laptop with a plasma screen there's one
of those out on display as well more RM
machines the intermedia system so this
was quite interesting this was a system
designed to convert different dis
formats three inch eight inch from the
quarter two other formats so you could
read from one disk and translate it to
another I've never seen another one of
those machines so this is the outer 8800
B this is the one with that style front
panel so that's the one you saw was the
one we have in the museum this is
another one we've got another one
because it's just a different front
panel the 8800 be there which is what's
known as the turnkey version so this was
basically the same thing except you
didn't have all the switches because you
were most likely going to connect it up
to a terminal and access it from there
and they're very rare hard disk
controller for the outer and floppy
drives for it as well little outset
collection they live it's kind of
interesting this is just a piece say a
Philips PC system but it links to a
laserdisc player so this system is
running educational software or not
educational training software what's
that what the Domesday was based do you
say system is very very similar Philips
laserdisc player except it has extra
Hardware underneath which is the
interface to the BBC micro this was
controlled purely from rs-232 from that
PC and this was used a Ford for training
software to show people how to do stuff
that system there is purely a word
processor that's the IBM display writer
so this part the floppy drives and the
keyboard and the prints are there gives
you a word processor it really is yeah
but display writer later on become
display right so all of this hardware
became software afterwards either to run
or any PC deck I think that's a
professional user found there and
there's a bit of a clean various
different SJ research networking things
for the BBC micro on a calls networking
stuff there canons early machines there
the a s100 is that Tonto or is that an
opt you never know right so this is an
OPD so this is ICL's computer this was
designed to be obviously on your desk
and you had a built-in phone
and connections so you could get onto
BBS's and view data type systems but
ultimately inside that is this
incorrectly well so it's basically a ql
with some plugin cartridges that gave it
some inbuilt software and up here are
two micro drive cartridges so that when
it's monitor they're set on your desk
and you have a ql but beefed up for
business use i see how were a big
mainframe manufacturer and i said this
was a departure for them right it was
yeah this is times getting to the more
personal side of things but it was
basically just that system and it was
rebranded then as a same system British
Telecom BT Merlin Toronto so bt going on
the ax as well there was a little bit of
a spite with companies producing probe
communications computers and slightly
miss reading where things were going oh
yes no yes or no they they were they
were you know genuine very good uses for
these things we've got a great system
over there as well I'll show you but you
know computing is mostly about
communications these days you know so
the whole connectivity with the internet
and sharing information
these were doing that kind of thing
obviously much much more simplified and
giving people instant access to stock
data and shares and whatever else so you
know sorry we don't have now because the
computer is much more general purpose
but it could have been that way
Terrace 80 there's a model two or one
that's a to great big 8 inch drives at
the side there keyboard sitting on top I
think so apricot machines there's n
we've got a couple of development
systems as well from apricot they
weren't quite PC compatible they were
close but not quite
close enough I remember seeing apricots
back in again thinking amazing but were
they just trying to rip off Apple
because of the names now there was a
boat thing that was it at all there were
lots of companies based around fruits I
don't really know why every thought that
would be a good name for these things
yeah I don't know but apricots were good
equipment they would they were very good
machines but they purposely decided to
make them very very slightly
non-standard so that they kept their
customer base so you had to buy their
version of the software for this machine
which autumn Utley would turn out to be
a bad idea you know everybody wanted
the floppy drives didn't quite run at
the same speed as everybody else's so
completely unreadable but then they did
produce a machine I think they call it
the chameleon apricot chameleon which
was then much more PC compatible but by
that time then kind of miss the bus kind
of ironic really because now it doesn't
really matter as long as the files are
the same it doesn't matter at all
because everything connects the same way
yeah absolutely yeah the physical media
is gone and you just spout it over the
internet but um but no but back then
that was obviously a big deal you needed
to take your floppy disk put it in a
envelopes into somebody else so you can
read your you know WordPerfect files or
whatever it might have been so so being
not compatible was a bit of a problem in
that way and ultimately leads to the end
of paper got really I don't know how
that got there because that weighs a ton
a micro frame computer again I've never
seen another one of those or anybody out
there knows anything about them
please let us know we've got an original
brochure for it but this is this is
metal from ways of absolute time I would
imagine probably pretty much it's just a
CPM based machine very incredible and
the monitor mounts directly to the to
the unit there
Commodore yeah so not many people know
that Commodore did end up making pcs
very basic ones 80 88 based I think or
86 a lot sure Diablo that's a Xerox
system there Tandy's that's again
effectively sturdy PC more apricots over
there
Olivetti that is just a data printer I
think so it's basically a terminal
printer terminal that's an old friend
for me my first PC experience for 286
uh-huh
my mum got forward processing but we
managed to get it to do all sorts of
course you weren't that great CGA
another world was the most impressive
yes absolutely
yeah no pieces at a time we're a little
bit limited so for games and things they
were weren't that great Prince of Persia
yeah the animation on Prince of Persia
was brilliant absolutely brilliant a
semi Roy machine there
that's a again 8-inch base it's
effectively CPM based system but so
there's a couple systems we've got with
different names about very very similar
systems amstrad's got a few of the
answers here
those kind of business machines there's
a digital there though is that word that
ring deck yeah that's a deck digitally
much much later on index life just a
peso nothing nothing to see there really
but but yeah we've got the deck alphas
and things at an alpha over there I
think there's an alpha in the background
there but yes I'm a master at machines
they're quite nice
alright the later Emma Strad pcs the
286s or 2:286 alone oh it's beasts yeah
yeah yeah and actually I mean that's
quite a big monitor the other one we've
got has gotten a very small monitor like
this and then the word processor again
these are other versions so we have the
a 2 5 6 on display but then we have the
85 1 2 as well so that we've got both oh
we just mentioned this in the other
video actually there is an exit ii
sorcerer no I like these why do I like
these because they're clearly no
production run and what I like most
about them is their cartridges so you
they have plug-in roms at the side but
when you take it out that's what they
look like
do you recognize that at all there's an
8-track cassette there is an 8-track or
say if you look at the end there you see
the way it's all been hacked out now I
love the idea that these things are
being manufacturer annex ADIZ company
somewhere and they've got a massive
power of Diana Ross tapes and they're
unscrewing them or we tape everywhere
hacking these edges and then put in
their circuit boards ooh well the thing
is I mean it was very production run so
this is very cheap molding cases it's
not it's not a quantity case there
should be a one of these things only in
there yeah but you know this is a
relatively low production run case I
don't know how many of these machines
they produced but they probably didn't
produce that many so this was
effectively 5 grams worth of machine in
today's UK money but yes I have a
cartridge made like that would have cost
you a lot for the injection moulding
would have been you know thousands and
thousands of pounds so why not use
8-track tapes at this time we're at the
end of their days they were probably
very very cheap to buy and it's probably
cheaper to pay somebody to take all the
tape out of it and then than it is to
get these things molded so actually I
think it's absolute genius I love it so
so yeah so that's the cartridges from
one of my favorites we've got the disc
interface and monitor all built in onto
that screen there and there's also sort
of expansion interface underneath it as
well
if that part of it was five grand I have
no idea what the complete system they
would cost plus software so yeah I love
the Exedy sorcerer we got a box Tron as
well in the in the archive over the road
as well we try and keep the original
boxes and manuals and everything else
where we can there are no menus here we
tend to separate those and these
software that come with and they're
separated out and somewhere else and
it's all sort of linked on the website
so we know where everything is
so that way we keep the best best
condition we can no deck 3000 s-s-so
decks higher end still stuff as opposed
to their PC stuff later this is a sony
in a sex machine
this and msx2 but it has an interface
that allows you to connect to that
laserdisc player as well a little bit
doomsday system like i'm seeing another
old friend up here put the boring era
for apple there were very much beige
boxes there wasn't too much thought
going into the design of what they look
like but they was perfectly capable
machines from the internals point of
view they were doing things nobody else
was doing right yeah yeah then the multi
Motorola stuff going on and yeah six to
eight thousand machines like they were
good wellspect machines um and like we
were talking earlier these things were
used for only multimedia so you know
producing videos on these things you
able albeit limited so um he was saying
sort of quarter frame yeah we we used to
do so my my introduction to video
editing was on a Power Mac very similar
to that and we couldn't do full frame
video you could do a quarter of a frame
and have a lot of black space around it
yeah yeah well you know that's what
people were impressed with you you had
CD ROMs that had limited space anyway we
weren't on DVDs or anything like that so
a multimedia cd-rom you had sort of 700
mega SH to play with so you couldn't
have a great deal of video anyway so
they were always very small little clips
that were part of another page so what's
the encyclopedia yeah Compton's
encyclopedia and in carter and stuff
like that had these little I'm not on
every article just on the few and and I
remember going through things like in
Carter back in the day and just looking
for the ones with video you know I
wasn't interested in the article if it
didn't have video you know and you get
this little I wasn't even 3-5-2 was it
across it was smaller than that but some
they were tiny were likely something
like 288
pixal something ridiculous and
compression standards were still
evolving and not a lot of the machines
could decompress much so yeah so it had
to be very minimal decompression because
the processes weren't capable of the
compressing life and yeah you you were
very limited but it was the beginning of
you know what we have now you know I
remember making websites with tiny I
don't know how many they were less than
100 pixels across video of a laser show
that was I was filming and I thought
that was amazing that people can go on
the web and see this tiny little video I
was it was huge but you know you look
back now it's bit of a joke but there
you go things change that's what we're
about
sorry moving on why don't we go I trying
to speed this up a bit
SWT PC only machine there Victor machine
we have HP 9 8 to 5 so these are kind of
again sort of scientific machines are
these we use for big glorified care
places in a way a couple there the a in
the B version not sure what the
difference is send yo machines PCs there
from segno our toss again these that
these are machines that were CPM based
but rather than plug in the monitor
you'll plug in a terminal so they have
lots of serial connections so you could
have eight users or something like that
all using that one system at the same
time and they had things like concurrent
CPM that allowed people to use the
operating system at the same time yes
this is interesting I've got two stories
on this one so this is for anybody that
recognise it part of the risk PC so we
got this PCE around No so anyway Elias
write anything so that's just standard
risk PC but you could have an extra
slice they call them slices which would
be one of these now the two stories are
the this was definitely the a called
world show and they had a risk PC that
was built up with lots and lots of extra
slices and somebody said that they the
piece Ravan was just a bit of a joke to
say you could add all these different
things to it and you can even have do
your pizza but actually other people
have said well it was a little bit more
aggressive than that that actually the
pizza oven it was part of the risk PC
they had on display it was trying to
show that Intel processors which used a
lot of power and therefore displayed a
lot of hate could cook a pizza so
actually their their arm processors were
way better
much lower power but Intel processors
you could cook your patron now I don't
know which of those stories is the more
accurate but they're both fun and yeah
basically I mean it's a bit dodgy
there's a mains connector there that
went in and powered this light here to
give it that kind of red glow I'm not
sure that would it be that would pass
pat testing today I don't think we're
plugging in no but you know kind of fun
and part of you know acorns I called
weld exhibition and they display I've
just realized actually this this is not
just a risk PC that is in fact a
prototype risk PC so yeah lots of stuff
here that is pre-production and
prototype and before the actual
production runs there's actually another
interesting machine there so this this
case doesn't look very interesting but
inside it is a machine called the profit
3 so this portable computer if I can get
out that's going to be recognizable to
quite a few people that know acorn as a
madam that's a rebadged atom but an atom
with a disk interface so you could take
around your Aten in this Kerri Kasem
so you got a carry handle there so you
could carry it around and on top you can
stick your monitor plug it into the
mains there take the composite video
output and away you go
you've got your portable PC so um yeah
that's the profit I think again that was
aimed at a specific market I think it
has a spreadsheet not built in but on
the disk so it was sort of for
accountants on the move for eighties and
again people recognized from school but
that is a very early and what they call
the blue box version not many of those
around in that kind of box more Amstrad
archimedes all the different versions of
Archimedes 310 440 441 got the risk
exposure over there so the r-1 40s and
r2 60s over there
so a con got insert Conover a different
operating system called risk exceeds are
more powerful machines and this was a
more the UNIX II high-end market but
obviously didn't go that far cambridge
workstation down there
they're quite rare than another
Cambridge a call machine that was again
towards the end of days for acorn sadly
memory 7,000 that's a huge lump of the
Machine screen built-in with its drives
there that the computer itself set in
front like that that's the memory 7000
the Enigma that's not the Enigma people
would first think off it's just the name
of it there were lots of companies
making CPM based machines there was kind
of no licensing issues it was a standard
Daisy based computer so lots of people
made their variations on it and so you
see a lot of these fact that galaxy
generally one there and the Enigma are
very nearly identical in fact they
probably are quite a few machines that
are rebranding that way this is quite
nice
carefully take no if not this issue but
that's just a laptop this has seen
better days but it's beautiful
in a very ugly kind of way so that is in
that's gone one no sorry it's an S con
so I think it's a computer built into a
great big wooden box
lovely so you've got the expansion board
there for memory you can add extra roms
onto it then that's gone ball is
underneath we get a lot of Nascars and
UK 101 that's built into various
flavours of wooden boxes no to look the
same is there another one yeah there's a
UK 101 up there in fact again this is
this is edging towards portable
computing so if we I love the hinges
yeah well the hinges uncover the
keyboard so yeah is it the the UK 101
was a it was a single ball computer you
bought it you you you put it together it
was one board with the keyboard built-in
yeah people build them into cases that
the suited them so you've got the
compartment at the back there which
gives you access to 240 volts if you
want to electrocute yourself any point
that's nice
so yeah I don't know why you need to
have a little compartment for that you
know I've written some really bad code
I'm musty like to keep myself I'm just
hoping this flap and kill myself I don't
know that I'm sure there was a
reasonable reason to be on suicide
probably kept overheating so they that
probably makes more sense I prefer my
version except that built in you know
brilliant how many people went to of
these links to
to a chordate their machines because
actually you know the machines were a
certain amount of money but maybe a
molded case that went with it was half
as much again so it's you know people
had to find other ways of casing their
machines if they'd made themself
we have compacts up there the early
compact portable machines really
important machine so this is the osborne
one kind of one of the first computers
that was popular as opposed as a
portable computer i'll try and show you
so they're not like they're not that
portable you would put that on your desk
you'll undo the catches she's difficult
to do when you hide it there you go so
you had this tiny all got some
information on it as well tiny little
screen full size keyboard full-size
floppy disks the thing they chose to
shrink was the screen the bit the really
want to keep her speaking she can
probably it was down to what was
available so these are all off-the-shelf
parts and they've all been squeezed into
this case and probably that screamers
may be used on a set of scopes or
something you know there would have been
some other use for that screen so
they've bought what is available and
made themselves a portable computer this
thing was incredibly popular this
started off really that train for mobile
computing portable computing and yes so
very very well this is the early version
with the with the blow molded case no I
put back in it in a minute back up there
but then very shortly after they started
producing a slightly more professional
version of it which has a slightly nicer
case but essentially same machine this
was one of the first machines actually
shipped with bundled software so when
you bought this you got yourself a
spreadsheet a database communication
software it all came with it basic so
the idea of having bundled software
having literally your whole office in a
briefcase suitcase was first done by
Osborne really quite important machine
that would later be followed by the
other machines that we saw up there so
these what form part of the halt and
catch fire story them yeah well yeah
corn I think these were the predecessor
to that that machine there with its
screen and its keyboard which is here
that is the IBM PC actually that's the
original the 5150 with two floppy drives
so this is a machine that IBM produced
it was quite unlike their machines that
went before because they used to make
all the parts of one of their machines
this machine used an Intel chip and it
used a pricing system from a
lesser-known company called Microsoft
and that was unusual for IBM that was
the first time they've done that and
this was kind of in answer to things
like the Apple two's that were starting
to appear around companies in mostly in
the States and IBM weren't too chuffed
about that so they kind of rushed this
product into existence and it was very
good it was expensive but it was a whole
king great machine metal case that sat
on your desk personal computing no
longer when you reliant on the company's
mainframe you can do what you wanted
with this machine so this is great so
that's the IBM PC what a company an
unknown company at the time called
Compaq did they took the idea that
Osborne we're doing this portable
machine and they made a similar kind of
product and they produced let me put the
feet up they produced a machine called
the pop compact portable now what's
important about this machine is that it
was a hundred percent compatible with
the IBM PC so whatever software you run
on your IBM machine and remember IBM
ruled the roost you know they were so
dominant in the computing industry it's
untrue
they would go reason but the software
that was written for that would run on
this machine even though it wasn't a
standard IBM machine there's so many
stories that go along with all these
machines and actually the stories is
what we can't find the most interesting
the hardware is just the excuse to tell
those stories so so yes it's really nice
when you can get one of these machines
and then talk about the things that it
did it made happen and the social
impacts of some of these machines you
get a lot of this stuff donated don't
you do you get a lot of those stories
from people who donate them yeah we make
sure we collect those stories quite
people are quite surprised to hear that
when they come in and say oh I've got
this machine would you like it the first
thing we would say you know is what have
you got it what did you use it for blah
blah blah and it you know people have
got really interesting stories you know
there's there's a
shared experiences with using them at
university to write their thesis and all
this kind of stuff but then some people
say what I was doing
you know computation for you know DNA
and all this kind of stuff we we have
SGI systems that are used to decode the
human genome
we've got other other machines that were
used for all sorts of different things
scientific research we've got machines
from the Scott Polar Research
we've got machines that were created the
Grattan catalog I know everybody
remembers that yeah massive catalogue
this thick that we had in the UK where
you could put stuff on tick and pay off
over the next 36 weeks and the shots the
shopping company yeah yeah but they're
huge yellow pages stole big catalogs and
and that machine was used to deal with
the data entry for that for instance
things that you just wouldn't really
think of but they're interesting and
what it's done for those people the way
that it's changed their lives people
that have had their their companies and
they've computerised them you know she
means he stole in a stock control system
or whatever but everything that went
along with that it's stuff that happens
today that you don't think about you
know it is obvious if you are gonna have
a business you're gonna have a confusion
that he's gonna look after your accounts
everything else but it wasn't always
like that you know sometimes it was
actually a lot more hard to work and
these machines are loud you know the
speed of business just increase so much
you know we used to send a letter to
another company and they would reply you
know to a week later or whatever if you
don't get replied to your email by the
end of the day no he's you know why
haven't they replied so it's it's
changed everything in that way and it's
because of these machines
that's what's interested in it you know
the hardware's great and the stories
that go along with them a you know
equally so so yeah so there's a lot of
memories for a lot of people in amongst
all this sort of stuff so yeah I can see
some of these machines you know this one
was controlling water processing plant
but we have another machine over there
that was used for controlling water flow
through a dam it's just incredible
incredible lots of commodores down here
another you comin up hep and then also
the later pets these are the Commodore
SK series so
so these were basically repackaged
versions of the earlier commodore pets
just in a nicer kind of space 1999 stole
cases really like those ones lorries on
the shelves like these but they go but
yes I mean it's just a small part of the
collection like I said I don't know you
know there's probably a couple of
hundred machines up here maybe I'm not
sure there's over a thousand in the
collection some of them are just in
boxes some of them in their original
boxes there's have a twelve thousand
bits of software archives so far in the
collection 9,000 magazines I don't know
how many thousand manuals and yeah it's
quite fast and it's and you can look at
all this stuff online just go on the
website if the machine is up here and
you've seen it it will be on the website
for the connoisseurs next time right
yeah absolutely there's some more stuff
here we can show you
we also go through some of these
machines on our own YouTube channel as
well so we have if you search YouTube
for Center for computing history and
also retro tech archive we've got two
channels if you want to follow those
awesome yeah follow the link wherever it
might be it's just got that sound of oh
oh Internet Explorer's opened again